[Musique]
bien dit biz l'isoler muscles ça va a
pris les choses ça m'a bien plu
davantage vers le corps humain un livre
des articulations
de l'umir la bure ce qu'on mange
[Musique]
aussi
débat les caractères du groupe lui il
n'a pas qu'une balle
les sentiments les particuliers
manger gauche more heroes heroes' sans
rire du pire il fait l'électronique qui
prend des photos
[Musique]
construire escalade c'était difficile et
en même temps drôle ce qu'il faut savoir
où ça se met tous ces bricoles et du
coup ça fait un truc du soleil mais ça
c'est des repas
[Musique]
c'est rigolo parce que rigole son
cerveau il colle
le
c'est bizarre ça me connaît
toujours d''acheter' à moi tout seul